Speaker 1: this next story.
You know, I feel sort of extra sad about this
only because we've been covering it from the
beginning.
Anti vaccine pro Trump.
Right wing radio host Phil Vallentine, who
had been in the hospital with covid for some
time now, has died.
And we started to wonder if things were taking
a turn for the worse sometime ago because
we were hearing from his family.
He's not exactly turning the corner.
And Phil Valentine has now died.
We covered this from the very beginning.
There's a Rolling Stone article laying it
out which explains a few days after Phil Valentine
announced he had tested positive for covid-19
on July 11th, the conservative talk show host
wrote on Facebook, He was doing my patriotic
duty for natural herd immunity, sort of suggesting
the way to get through this is for people
to get sick and recover and develop herd immunity.
This was a pretty big radio host.
He had a national show on 100 stations for
12 years.
He openly questioned vaccines on his show.
He mocked the vaccination campaign with a
song, vaccination, parodying the Beatles Taxman.
He said, I am certainly not getting the vaccine
now, he said on July 14th, saying I have full
immunity on the basis of his positive covid
diagnosis.
He is now dead at 61 and as we had been following,
his condition worsened steadily since being
diagnosed.
He was in the hospital a full two weeks and
then placed on a ventilator on July 30th.
His brother said he was being transferred
to an ECMO machine, which is now.
We're talking not just ventilation, we're
talking a machine that does the work of the
heart and lungs fill, Valentine wrote on Facebook
on July 13th.
You need to have a plan in case you get covid.
Make sure you get your vitamin D three level
checked and have a doctor on speed dial.
Listen to this.
Who will write you a prescription for ivermectin?
Ivermectin is a drug used to treat livestock,
heifers, horses, mares, et cetera, for worms.
And this is what some have been advocating
for.
You've seen it on Fox News.
You've seen it elsewhere.
I'm Phil Vallentine saying, if you're at high
risk of dying from covid, I still strongly
suggest you consider the vaccine.
Just make sure you're prepared if you decide
against the vaccine.
I'm not going to go on and on and on talking
about all the different things that Phil Valentine
said.
But needless to say, he is now dead from coronavirus.
Now, we heard from Republican Senator Marsha
Blackburn, Republican Senator Marsha Blackburn
tweeted about this and she said Phil Valentine
was a visionary for the conservative movement.
And he made an enormous impact on the lives
of many Tennesseans.
My deepest condolences and prayers are with
Phil's wife, Susan, and his family.
May they be comforted and surrounded by love
during this difficult time.
You know, I would really respect Senator Marsha
Blackburn more or at all because I my respect
level for her is zero right now.
I would respect her if she used this as an
opportunity to say get vaccinated.
This is really serious, Phil, with 61 and
as far as we know, healthy, although I'm not
totally sure.
And he went out of his way for a while to
say no horse the wormer instead of vaccines
and he's dead now.
She didn't do that.
She didn't even refer to the irresponsible
nature of his anti-tax campaign.
Now, if we have to find anything here that
maybe we could say, is there any silver lining?
Phil Valentine did become pro vaccine in his
final days and he started encouraging people
around him and messages getting out through
the radio station through his brother, saying
he now says, go and get yourself vaccinated.
It is actually possible.
Again, this is it's a bad situation.
But if we can find something in it, it's possible
that he will save some lives by virtue of
becoming pro vaccine and talking about it
to a crowd that would be disproportionately
vaccine skeptical right wingers.
His audience, once he was very sick, it didn't
save him.
And he still promoted the horse, the wormer
ivermectin, really dangerous weaponized stuff.
But maybe, maybe he will actually be responsible
for some lives saved by virtue of the fact
that he lost his own life statistically because
he did not go and get himself vaccinated.
Some people get vaccinated and die, but very
few in all likelihood being vaccinated would
have saved his life.
Now he is dead.
Maybe his followers will follow his most recent
advice, which is go and get yourself vaccinated.
It's it it's really reminiscent of the Jonestown,
Jim Jones Temple, stuff like where he's talking
about, you know, follow him.
And if I told you to drink cyanide laced Kool-Aid,
would you?
And eventually he gave the cyanide laced cool.
I mean, the ivermectin stuff is essentially
that at this point.
Will you on my say so, do you trust me enough
that you will take the heart d wormer, which
you might have to get from a veterinarian,
although there are some medical doctors that
are actually making it easy for people to
get?
It's crazy what's going on.
And a little bit later, we'll talk about what's
happening in Mississippi.
It's a dystopian covid hell scape in Mississippi
that is getting to or even surpassing what
is happening in Florida, Mississippi and Alabama,
increasingly the covid hellholes of the United
States.
All of that coming up.
Make sure to let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And by the way, we are now only five and a
half million YouTube views from one billion
YouTube views.
When we get to that billion, we're going to
do a huge membership special.
You can be notified by getting on my newsletter
at David Pakman Dotcom.
But what a number one billion views coming
up really, really soon.
All right